look I got these what's that hope you
don't mind but he's yeah we see these
yeah I'm going them
[Music]
Oren's no no hair your hair see the nuts
yeah look II know you're like trails go
away burn get ready to cut him off too
because this new job I'm doing right now
I'm moving in with him so I gotta shave
all this up so I gotta go
so hope this doesn't look terrible
okay I was born November 11th 1962 on
Veterans Day flowered for August footage
second drop 57 I'm trying to explain to
you to understand that he needs up my
chest you know my mom died on my
birthday
I'll be quiet we're gonna leave a little
bit
let's look good finish so if I ever get
through this maybe never
I want to marry early no this is what
this is what being married is like get
used to it now or get out up so I'm
never happy
an invention friends so you guys are
doing drugs like the people here at Skid
Row you guys are drinking well I was
like but there's no no drugs your
favorite drink vodka vodka yeah her yeah
yeah and really asleep easily place yeah
tent there now we sleep on the sidewalk
then where do you eat at sellers no
usually I go to Subway or El Pollo locos
where do you get the money I just look I
am the kind of person if I tell you I'm
hungry
you better help me out with something to
eat I'm gonna get food but when I come
to my defect I'm not hungry
I'm my alcoholic I need your money for
something to drink dad we're not like
that so tell me about your parents when
you were a child okay I'll make sure
my dad left my mom and me my sister and
I went deeper five years old
he went to raise another man's bike it's
not even his own flesh and blood because
he is our power got cut up in our
apartment and my mom went and got rocks
I put a grill over and set a fire to the
table so he could cook it something and
then that man had enough balls to come
back would hit
another man sent in a private plane oh
man what and as soon as I you gonna go
deny your own flesh and blood to bridge
another man's kid and leave your own
kids without
I got to forgive but I can never protect
God forgave me a much said so that means
I can t give him any hits but I'll never
forget
ripped up tonight but your children
remember cigarettes [ __ ]
and that is my best friend
Bob always appreciate your your
childhood tell me about your parents
okay
[Music]
now that I've got hurt I've kind of hurt
doing her in the ICU please
she is like that
I Carolina matters so my childhood
[Music]
my dad was kind of addicted
yep food new refrigerator we had bounced
around a little bit good holy job and he
was not logged in
and so
just like that
and
this part in a picture didn't last that
long because my stepdads
yes
[Music]
and basically what happened there is I
aim at it out first son of my mom
and so she was very proud to have a son
so anyways he stepped in he said you
know if you're just Bentley one more
time I'm taking over so we did my debt
and we didn't like each other for 20
years
these last 10 years became very infest
so last time we spoke you were here with
Debbie yep and she just kept
interrupting captain Rodney so you never
really get to finish your story I don't
know where I'll also I remember very
well you're telling me about November is
this cursed one for you
and your sister you were starting to
tell us the story of your sister that's
where it all started and would happen
right there was she went on a toy run
you know just three years
motorcycling parties and so she went out
run right there and we ended up with a
flat tire
and so they call triple-a the edribali
and he called and he changed the tire
which ran across it was right there on
Topanga row and you know PCH Yeah right
and she ran across the road order take a
lead in the rocks rocks away there and
disgusting she went it's got smacked by
a corner oh yeah and a guy was drinking
you know so
that's why I can't make drinking driving
never so that was the ultimate Brad
senior the family does that happen in 77
and she just affirmed 18 okay and you
know it was day before Thanksgiving and
also we got a true for knocking on the
door you know state trooper not gonna
door and you know we need to clean you
know Scott so that was a nightmare
so forget all about Thanksgiving you
know forget all about that Marcus and my
mom tried to blue like step dead
wouldn't make it to the funeral
one of my younger sister he's one year
older than me there's no way she could
have made it but I had those first time
in my old life they ever had a suit and
tie on hoagie is last
so so what happened your nose I'm okay
I work for a little baggie 7-eleven he's
my place right now I had pretty close to
about 100 bucks my arm so I'm going
downstairs and I lost my buddy because I
was wearing size 11 shoes no that's
pretty bad
how does it hurt
I'm not no good yeah I got aimed every
year and so after I you know I had the
victim cargo a big scar look just right
over the top this way to cut that open
recapping after he didn't try to run to
the bathroom had washing hold on who the
portal without that beef yeah it was a
smash smash I look back on laughs yeah
so your other family members your
brothers and sisters
I haven't seen my brother in 35 years
he is younger than me I got a sister
lives in Washington State
I haven't seen her in 30 years but I
have doctor run along and my other
sister he ended up falling tanning my
second oldest sister she is a blow her
brains out it's exactly the same beat my
mom died my arms my mom passed away in
tamii after that two years later on the
same day
put a bullet know so it was like never
give up
I just know you love